namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambhodassa namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambhodassa namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambhodassa
homage to the buddha the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one uh so well i've chosen this topic of courage but i've been really what we're talking about is fear isn't it overcoming fear
Now, fear is, I would argue, is the most fundamental of our emotional states, dependent on delusion.
So this delusion of a self, it's created a self which feels uncertain because, you know, sickness, aging and death and all that.
and therefore it has this fear about itself and it reacts to this fear by making itself safe and that's when we start accumulating stuff so money makes us feel safe got a big bank account lots of friends and power of course and lots of lots of uh pleasurable things to do so we keep our mind off these horrible things
So this fear of death or fear of sickness, etc., aging and all that, it has this effect of making us try to escape it.
And of course, this is one of the great awakeners.
This was the awakener, the awakeners that drove the Buddha to seek liberation, sickness, aging and death.
So it obviously plays a big part in our lives.
and uh it shapes our behavior you know when we're in any any any any situation which is dangerous or stressful or in any way a challenge so it's something we need to uh to deal with and i'm sure all of you have to some extent or other and uh it won't go you see until the very last moment when the self is destroyed so it's going to be with us for a while
And we have to see it as a friend.
I mean, after all, it is trying to protect us, right?
And so we have to give it a hug and then we have to sort of open up to it, get the feel of it and not run away from it.
So, of course, that running away from it is a panic, isn't it?
So if we consider the amount of fear that we have as a measure of the delusion of self, every time we undermine this fear, we're undermining the delusion of self.
So there is a plus to it.
And in fact, the Buddha in the Dhammapada, verse 39, tells us that in the end, all fear would disappear.
This is what he says.
For one who has awakened, whose mind isn't agitated, whose heart isn't tormented, and who has abandoned both merit and demerit, fear does not exist.
So once the mind has been silenced and the heart calmed, and there's no attempt to create karma based on a self, me creating stuff,
uh fear is completely gone so so the the prognosis is good this is what we have to keep remembering now uh psychologists have delineated six areas of experience where we experience fear and i'm indebted to gwen for this who runs the uh monthly meeting on climate change climate crisis
So it's the physical, the social, moral, emotional, intellectual and spiritual.
This is sometimes where we need to find a certain level of courage.
So the physical, I think, is pretty straightforward, you know, just straightforward, the fear of pain, fear of debilitating illness, etc.
So whenever that touches us, we come across this fear and it's being able to sit with the fear, allow it to arise, pass away.
That's the courage, the internal courage.
Of course, some people have to find that physical courage in daily life.
You know, I'm thinking of sports.
A lot of sports demand physical courage, especially boxing.
I don't know if any of you have done a bit of boxing, but you definitely got to have a bit of physical courage there.
And then there are occupations, you know, soldiering.
if we think of what's happening now in in the ukraine both sides demands a physical courage even the police that sometimes need that so uh this identity with the body is profound yeah i mean you can't be here without one so i mean it's the physical representation of our existence so uh it's important that we
Whenever this comes to us, that we really turn towards it, see it as a friend, see it that it's actually trying to protect us and almost get comfortable with the feelings of fear.
That's the big thing, not to push it away.
um so we may use that as a sort of questions of ourselves have there has there been a time in our lives when we've been physically timid when we should have done something and how do we feel about that is there some guilt and shame that we haven't worked through and then you know to make these silent inward resolutions that if it's demanded of us we'll do our best to manifest courage
So that's the physical part.
The social part usually is to do with feeling embarrassed in a meeting.
So you don't want to ask a question in case people think it's silly and stuff like that.
So we're afraid of criticism, you know, saying something which other people will jump down our throats for, things like that.
Even sort of expressing ourselves to neighbours, to a neighbour who
whom you know has a different opinion or a different understanding.
So that sort of social courage is sometimes, you know, sometimes that really we have to try to express.
So, I mean, obviously we have great examples of that, you know, Martin Luther King, Nelson Mandela.
All these people who are out on demonstrations, which are getting to be more and more policed and more danger of being fined and sent to prison.
And of course, when you think of countries and the amount of courage you need, like, for instance, that terrible time in Iran where the Morality police murdered that young woman.
and the the tremendous repressive measures that the government took you know even capturing you know capturing people and then hanging them uh we've got of course russia so you've got a a man called um cara murza
who is a political activist, journalist, author, filmmaker, political prisoner.
So he spoke against the present war and he's ended up in jail for 25 years.
And unless Putin is somehow got rid of, he's going to be there for 25 years.
And then, of course, there's that Russian opposition leader, Navalny, who's, I think, tremendously courageous.
It's unbelievable, really, whom Putin actually tried to poison.
Even if you look back into Russian history, the misery of the Russians is unbelievable.
I don't think it's quite remarkable.
And yet they find this courage through, if you remember Stalin's time, when the Samizdat, when they were writing poems and all sorts of stuff and passing it on bits of paper to friends, trying to keep the resistance alive.
and uh and of course there's the investigative journalist the 67 been murdered last year the most prominent of course was then the israeli forces shot murdered shireen abu akleh in the occupied west bank is awful awful awful so again it's just you know social courage it's again an opportunity for us to contemplate where you know we haven't made our views known out of fear out of fear of criticism or whatever
being mocked attacked and again there might be some shame or guilt around that so you have to work through it you know you have to allow it to come up and and then to make that resolution you know should I find myself in such a situation I'll I'll make my understandings known yeah sort of shading into that is moral courage um
It's more to do with right and wrong, you know.
And I'm reminded now of the 60s, which of course is prehistoric now.
But we had a person in the UK called Mary Whitehouse who really led the charge against, you know, the loss of moral compass.
In those days it was called permissiveness and people were getting very upset about it.
And of course we did lose the moral ground.
We found out about the behavior of that famous DJ, Jimmy Savile, and then the Catholic priests and all that and pedophiles.
So it was all, I mean, there was something happened in the 60s which sort of took away a grounding that we used to have as a society in morality.
But of course, these situations are never absolutely white and black.
It's quite difficult to decide.
Then we have things like abortion, which in Europe is now sort of a dead subject, really.
But we can see the tremendous war that's going on in the United States over it.
And the usual sort of battle between the mother's rights and the right of the fetus.
And I think more upfront these days for us is immigration and the impact it's having on society.
And no one has a clue.
I mean, I haven't a clue as to what the answer is to the growing level of immigration.
And when climate change really begins to bite, presumably it's going to get much worse.
These people are coming out of areas of abject poverty and almost unlivable.
And on top of that, there's the political refugees.
So, of course, the danger here is that it pushes society to, the indigenous society, we can say, to defend itself and move over towards fascist regimes, which is happening.
You know, we've got Orban in Poland.
We've got Maloney in Italy.
And this comes out of fear, you know, but it's something that...
If we want to maintain a liberal society, something we really have to tackle.
So again, there's this whole area of morality which demands courage.
And, you know, has there been a time in the past we could have been more morally courageous?
And again, to make that resolution.
The next one is the emotional courage.
Well, that points to, you know, opening up to these very difficult mental states that we have within ourselves.
And that's, of course, very much part of our practice of vipassana, just to allow, you know, very difficult mental states to arise and to be able to see the aversion that we have to it, the fear that we have to it, and just to allow that to pass away.
know and then just to sit quietly with it to to sort of sink into the fire tie ourselves to the bonfire and just allow it to rage and we do that because that's the healing you know once once these emotions have a chance to liberate themselves they um of course what we mistake is that when we begin them begin to create these stories in the mind and it feels like a relief
if you if you're angry and you go off onto a fantasy of beating somebody up then it feels like a relief but actually it's just it's just uh exercised the anger it's when you feel it as a physical sensation that it's actually being released so this of course we know through our vipassana and uh there's a little passage here that i've copied from the buddha who has had to tackle fear
when he first went out into the jungles.
And while I was staying there, a wild animal would come, or a peacock would make a twig fall, the wind would rustle the falling leaves, and the thought would occur to me, is this that fear and terror coming?
And then the thought occurred to me, why do I just keep waiting for fear and terror?
So instead of that, this is what he determines.
What if I, in whatever state I'm in, when fear and terror come to me, were to subdue that fear and terror in that very state?
So when fear and terror came to me while I was walking backwards and forwards, I would not sit down or stand or lie down.
I would keep walking backwards and forwards until I had pacified the fear and terror.
When fear and terror came to me while I was standing, I would not walk or sit or lie down.
I would keep standing until I had subdued the fear and terror.
And when fear and terror came to me while sitting, I would not lie down or stand up or walk.
I would keep sitting until I had subdued that fear and terror.
When terror and fear came to me while I was lying down, I would not sit up or stand or walk.
I'd keep lying down until I had subdued the fear and terror.
so uh in other words he you know he turned towards it yeah the word subdue just suggests some sort of suppression but that's not what he means so again you know if uh if we have a specific mental state that arises that we find very difficult you know to find you know if it comes up at a convenient time when it's just you by yourself whatever
just to be able to move into it and stay with it.
And then there's the intellectual.
So here, oops, just a minute, we've got something wrong here.
Then there's the intellectual.
So recently here in the UK, we had a Professor Kathleen Stock, who's a philosopher and a gender critical academic.
And she's been hounded out of the university that she worked in.
And there was a whole rumpus at Oxford University asking her to be cancelled.
And she basically stated in her book that trans women are not, it's difficult to say, are not the same as born women.
Let's put it that way.
So that's created quite a rumpus.
And of course, she lost the job and everything from it.
So this whole area is one where people have to have the courage to speak their truth, you might say.
It's a sort of dodgy area because it depends which way you're looking at it.
One of the paradoxes of this particular argument is nobody complains about a woman who becomes a man, changes her gender to a male.
And I presume that because there's not much problem with that.
So if a trans man walks into a male toilet, it's not a problem for the men.
And if they happen to be in the same sport, you know, boxing or something like that, it wouldn't be a big problem for men.
But on the other side, it's obviously some women feel threatened by it, you know, in hospitals, in toilets and in sport, you know.
So it's a difficult area.
And we need to think about it because there may come a time that we have to express our views, our opinions, and feel free to do so.
I mean, here in the West, you know, we have that freedom.
Interestingly enough, I just got here, in Hindu or Buddhist countries, and I think also true in the Far East, there isn't this obsession with sex at all.
And the funny thing is that
In the East, Buddhist especially, there's a sort of myth that you're much better off to become enlightened if you happen to be born a man.
So many women make the determination to be born a man in the next lifetime.
And there was a case in Sri Lanka, which is the opposite, where a Catholic bishop became a Buddhist.
And towards the end of his life, this is, I think, going back to the 60s, 50s, 60s, towards the end of his life, he determined that he wanted to be reborn as a woman.
So he began dressing as a woman and sort of trying to change his gender before he died.
Anyway, it really is just a case, intellectually, of really being able to hold our views and opinions just a bit more lightly, to see them more as perspective.
If you hold onto your views and opinions too strongly, you know, I'm right and everybody else is wrong,
then there's always conflict.
But to be able to be open to critique, to have your views challenged, even nuanced, I mean, that really takes courage.
And then finally, we have the spiritual courage.
And there's one little example here, which I think really affected me when I found this out.
When the Inquisition started,
and they attacked the Cathars, the Albigensians, down in the south of France.
What's today is the south of France.
There was an occasion where about some escaped from the first town that was attacked in Béziers, and they ended up in a place called Minerves, which was a heavily well-fortified small town with a river running through it, etc.
And there was a certain Simon de Montfort who was really quite a cruel soldier.
Anyway, they were eventually conquered and he just kept lobbing stones at them, you know, with a catapult.
Anyway, when they finally collapsed and they entered into the town, they built a big bonfire and 140 Cathars threw themselves onto the flames.
That's courageous.
And ironically, there is a monument to that right in front of the Catholic Church.
That's a bit cheeky.
So in our actual spiritual practice, there is, remember, this whole process of renunciation, of letting go, letting go, letting go.
And really, this idea of nibbana, you know, it's a sort of shady idea.
The Buddha tells us it's the highest happiness.
It's absolutely you want it when you've got it.
But we don't know what it is.
And in the Christian tradition, they talk of the mysterium tremendum and fascinans.
So it's the mystery which is both frightening, makes you tremble, and yet it fascinates you.
Yet you want to find out what it is.
So it's going to take some courage because it's like you're walking backwards towards a cliff.
You know, there's a drop coming somewhere.
You know, you've got to let go of everything at some point, but you don't know when it's coming and you haven't a clue what's going to happen when you actually fall off the cliff.
So there's a bit of anxiety, fear, existential anxiety around the whole process of spiritual practice.
So again, whenever that sort of fear comes up, we just turn to it, the usual thing, give a hug, it's only trying to protect us and make a determination to continue with our practice.
So these six areas just give us a way of examining the whole idea of
timidity when fear comes and courage there is another side to this which uh i'll tackle on another talk and that of course is the courage of forbearance the courage of patience and the buddha has a lot to say about that yeah very good so i can only help my words of being of some assistance that i have not caused confusion
and that by your ability to stay with fear, to overcome fear, you will be liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.